what does the filmmaker need to know
about cinematography these days I mean
oh good question in general or these
days or both these days yeah
now that DSLRs are just so easy to
operate
yeah should someone let's suppose
someone wants to be a writer director
should they know what it feels like to
have a camera in their hands oh
absolutely I think I think that be
having a having a command of
cinematography is there is probably one
of the most important things for a
director doesn't matter whether you're a
studio director or independent director
I think understanding cinematography
because as pretentious as this sounds I
am with I hate this but the camera is
the brush right so imagine you know not
feeling comfortable being a painter or
not feeling comfortable holding that
brush your not going to express yourself
as clearly so I think there's also an
intimidation because you know I was this
way I was never a techno you know I was
never a technocratic you'll hear about
like someone like Brian De Palma being
somebody who would like take apart a
radio as a child to figure out every
every diode or whatever you call it you
know I never had that interest I never
was a technical I would never fetishized
the technical but I didn't want to
understand how to best communicate the
images that were in my head on film and
to do that you have to understand the
camera more importantly probably the
most important thing is understanding
lenses and understanding that you know a
lens a close-up on a wide-angle lens and
a close-up on the long lens and I close
up on a quote-unquote normal lens or
have you know three totally different
emotional qualities and it starts by
looking at different filmmakers and
trying to determine and you don't have
to do it yourself we talked about this
earlier you can also read about you know
what technical choices they've made in
American cinematographer magazine or in
listening to directors commentaries but
just knowing the what's the quality of a
wide-angle lens and if you watch a film
by the Coen brothers or Orson Welles or
John Frankenheimer or Roman Polanski
we're starting start to understand that
not only is the field of view slightly
wider than other film
acres but there's a drama to to the way
the lines and the seedlings are are
stretching across and there's a there's
a difference between the way those films
look and say a film by Michael Bay which
may even though he uses wide lenses will
end up using a 500 millimeter lens or a
lot of long lenses and then where the
background is is blown out and the depth
of field is very narrow and it's
important to distinguish that and not
just think about shot size but what is
the focal length of that particular
close-up and what does it feel like to
you and we'll the way to do that with a
DSLR is to experiment a most people have
a zoom lens and to set the lens at a
focal plane like set the lens at its
widest and then start doing different
types of shots with only that lens don't
zoom in to get closer but step forward
and see what that looks like and take a
lot of different angles and pictures
with that particular lens move it to the
middle of your zoom which probably is
somewhere in the 50s you know somewhere
in the middle and do the same thing and
do the same thing with the longest part
of your lens if you want to do a
close-up on a 200 millimeter if that's
the end of your zoom then you'll have to
get back a little farther and look at
those and then put them together and say
you know what for a scary moment maybe
the wide-angle lens for a moment where
this person is sad and isolated and
alienated maybe the long lens where I
want to you know make the background to
make them detach from the background I
mean you can make all there is no set
vocabulary that says a wide angle equals
sadness or a long lens equals anxiety or
any of those things but it's important
for a filmmaker to I think to create
their own little vocabulary and say or
just to say I like the look of this I
like the look of this lens and that's
why I think so many filmmakers Kubrick
is another one you know where there are
these dynamics to the visuals because
they're aware of of the lens that is
best suited for that particular moment
so that's a long answer to starting with
just understanding
focal length you know it's a huge thing
and then there's so many other aspects
of cinematography which is you know when
does a static shot when is a static shot
more effective than a moving shot camera
height you know should everything be
right here it is it better to look at
the moment from here or from up here and
then something is little I'm joking but
then there's lighting which is the whole
other thing which is all but I think it
should all be I think the thing to think
about is think about in terms of how to
best express the emotions of the scene
it's not just about recording the moment
it's how do you understand with this
particular tool that you have and I know
as a young filmmaker this is a long way
around as a young filmmaker I was
intimidated about the camera it's like
the DSLR is not so intimidating but it
still can be certainly you know when I
was fooling around with my first bigger
16 millimeter cameras and then 35mm
cameras you're like you're looking at
this like it's this big you know it's
like a rocket ship that you just too
many dials on it and what does it do
really it's still just a recording
device with a piece of glass on it and
the more you handle this thing
particularly with the DSLR the more you
go out and just hold that thing the more
you physically shoot the more later as a
director you're going to be able to
direct your cinematographer to put the
camera here on this particular lens and
move it from here to here and that and
you start to call lenses I want a 28
millimeter lens here and you can say
that with authority or every every real
strong director is going to be able to
not only say what the shot is but where
the camera should go and on what lens if
you do that you're only going to be able
to do that if you've done it yourself
because then you know what you're
talking about
otherwise you're just pretending and I
was always afraid of being one of those
directors that just I used to see these
directors when I was like a freshman at
film school I would see these
upperclassmen who were like posing they
were just interested in like you know
looking like a director and saying
action and you know all this [ __ ] and I
was like yeah but that dude doesn't
really know what he's talking about and
it seems like the crew is making the
movie and this guy's just you know like
sitting up on his high horse like he's
in charge but he's not he's not taking
the image in his head and putting that
down with authority so in order to do
that
you have to become familiar with the
camera you don't have to be a master you
just have to be not afraid of it and you
have to be able to tell the difference
and things like focal length for you I
like it I like it on the long lens so
let's shoot this movie on a long lens or
I like I like the wide lens cuz I like I
like the dynamics that gives like the
energy that that gives I like the
distortion the more you handle it the
more comfortable you become then you can
direct with with confidence how about
playing with the settings the ISO the
f-stop like like how because sometimes
you get in a moment you think oh this is
going to be great and then when the
light changes and then you're under a
pressure situation or and if you're not
familiar you're not with the camera you
could just tell I think that's the I
think that that's yes those sort of
fundamental things and and it's and
fundamental things are important like
knowing how to who you know put the
image in focus should not be you know
undervalued and certainly understanding
what an aperture is and how to open the
aperture to allow more light or how to
in combination with the shutter speed
you know that if you're starting to run
out of light not only will you have to
open up the lens but you might have to
lower the shutter speed because you have
to allow more light into to just get an
image all those like those those sort of
fundamentals of photography which again
are not that many I mean there's there's
really just like you said there's
there's there's the is oh there's the
shutter speed there's the aperture and
there's a focus ring and that's
basically that's it you know that's
that's that's that's that's like when
you know when you go into a mixing room
it's so funny how you stick when I used
to start mixing movies and you go into
these mixing rooms which are very
similar to a music mixing room where
you've got a big board and you've got
10,000 faders you know they seem to go
on for infinity and there's all these
knobs and I would look at the mixers and
go it like geez how do you what what
does every one of these things do and
they're like well actually it's all we
really need to do oh we really
controller like these three and these
three and everything else is like and so
a camera is like that you may look at it
like it's got all these bells and
whistles but they're only you know half
a dozen or even less particular features
that really control
the image so I think most most young
filmmakers are getting to that place
earlier because they now possess a
camera that is closer to a professional
or is a professional camera so yes but I
I think the biggest you know mistake is
to defer that that's all important tool
to somebody else like I don't need to
bother with that camera I will Express
you know the mood that I have and then
this cinematographer will magically
interpret it and the image will come out
exactly as I to me that's just a long
way around you might as well just be
able to say here you know here's the
composition at this site on this lens
and then then the cinematographer who
arguably knows more about all these
things or is able to bring that much
more visually to the table will then
build upon something and make it even
better
but you don't want to rely upon a
cinematographer to invent your image
because then what are you doing then
you're really only directing the actors
and if you're going to do that then you
might as well directly
you